-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night.
We hope you're
doing well tonight.
And now, if you don't mind,
we're going to get to the news.
When asked why he thinks
he's trailing behind
former President Trump
in some recent surveys,
President Biden told reporters
last week that he's beating
Trump in eight out of ten polls.
Though, for what it's worth,
they're both still trailing far
behind literally anyone else.
President Biden on Thursday
met with members of the
United Auto Workers in Illinois
and wore a red
UAW T-shirt.
Yes, the outfit
of the common man.
A T-shirt over a button down.
He looks like he ran out
of clean laundry
and had to wear
everything inside out.
South Carolina
Senator Tim Scott
announced that he has suspended
his presidential campaign
in a Fox News
interview yesterday,
and said he thinks the voters
are telling him, quote,
"Not now, Tim."
And I think
he made the right call
because half of them said,
"Not now, Jim."
That's right.
Tim Scott yesterday suspended
his presidential campaign,
though something tells me
we haven't seen
the last of Tim Scott.
Okay, now we have.
That's probably the end of it.
The Biden administration
announced on Friday
that the Department
of Veterans Affairs
will expand health benefits,
including a no cost option
for those who served
in World War II.
Oh. Very generous.
What else are you offering?
Free insulin
for Civil War veterans?
Former President Trump
reportedly held
an off-the-record dinner
for reporters
last night at Mar a Lago,
and served Mr. President's
wedge salad.
Trump has a signature salad?
What?
What is it,
ranch dressing on a Big Mac?
The so-called QAnon Shaman
filed paperwork last week
to run for Congress in Arizona
as a moderate Republican.
[ Laughter ]
A state lawmaker in Florida
recently introduced a new bill
that would create
a Margaritaville-themed
license plate.
Well, that ought to save time
with the breathalyzer.
According to a new report,
the average rent
in New York City
decreased last month,
but only because everyone
added another roommate.
After a deer in new Jersey
recently dented the side
of a Chevy Silverado
right before its owner
was set to sell the car,
the man reduced
the car's price by $1,000
while the deer's family
was reduced by a buck.
[ Laughter and groaning ]
I'll apologize
for the rent joke two back,
but I'll [bleep] die
on this hill.
Everything about that joke
is perfect.
If you want to sit there
and groan
because you didn't think
of that joke, that's fine.
But that's the only
reason to be upset.
A man in Australia
recently survived
a crocodile attack
by biting it,
causing the animal
to let him go.
And if I know Australians,
it was the third thing
he mentioned when he got home.
[Australian accent] "Yeah,
boss was a real jerk today.
Oh, I saw Kendra.
She changed her hair.
Oh, and I bit a croc."
[Normally] Been getting a lot
of complaints recently
about how good
my Australian accent is,
but I think we pretty safely
put those to bed.
And finally,
according to --
Oh, wait a second, I --
Buck also means dear.
I apologize -- I'm so --
[Bleep] grow up.
And finally, according to new
analysis by an adult website,
the most searched sex position
in the country
is the pretzel,
followed closely
by "chiropractor near me."
And that was a monologue.